today's topic is secure DNS before the
end of this video you know what it is
how it works and why it's important now
Jeff the security guy you propose this
topic and at first what I thought you
meant was just DNS where you have a user
which visits a website say for example
ibm.com
and then this DNS server maps that box
into an IP address
maybe you meant like the encryption or
something like that and that then allows
them to return to what the page they
want to see
but that's not what you were talking
about no what's the security implication
here that I'm concerned about yeah so
what could happen is if you had a bad
guy let's say up here and the bad guy
were to get into the DNS and poison it
in other words make it so that it
doesn't point to the actual IBM address
in fact it gives a resolution that goes
back to this guy and points him to some
other place that is not the actual
website then he's going to come up here
to the hacker controlled website and now
he could he's basically a victim he
could end up entering his personal
information in a place he didn't mean to
he could end up uh end up downloading
ransomware or other malware that's one
use case where there's been a poisoning
That's occurred here now that doesn't
happen all that frequently but there is
also the possibility that this guy could
send an email over here oh so we're
talking about fishing now right exactly
and in the email it might say click here
for ibm.com but in fact it's obscured
and what it's actually going to point to
is this so this this is some other
website this is some kind of fake
website and the resolution is going to
come into here this DNS is going to
Faithfully resolve that and give him
back an IP address that points him to
the wrong place so instead of being
ibm.com it's IBM fakehackwebsite.com or
something like that and he's not going
to be aware of it that's like when you
see an efficient email where they have
one little change of a letter which at
first glance looks perfectly legit but
in fact is taking you off somewhere else
okay so how is it we're going to address
that problem so a better way to do this
is to have a DNS that is more
trustworthy that's designed for security
designed for privacy designed for all of
these kinds of things and an example of
that is something that comes from an
organization called quad nine in Quad
nine you would replace the DNS here and
instead send your domain names your URLs
to quad nine quad nine then resolve
solves them and what quad 9 is doing is
maintaining a blacklist of known bad
websites so this bogus website up here
would be in The Blacklist and when you
sent the request down to get resolution
you would not get back anything you get
like a 404 or server not yeah something
on those lines so you in other words
there's literally no way for you to get
to there because you don't even know
what the numeric IP address is for that
site this thing was looking out for you
and blocked you from ever getting there
in the first place so that essentially
protects me from a potential phishing
attack exactly but there's also to look
at other parts of this the performance
and privacy considerations like right
now today you probably have your DNS is
through your ISP or if you have a mobile
phone through them right yeah and
honestly we also know that they have a
potential profit motive there how does
that picture play out here with quad
nine well the good news is quad 9 is a
non-profit organization so they don't
profit from your information
there's an old saying that says if
you're not paying for it you're the
product not the customer well in this
case that's not the case because in fact
you're not paying for Quad nine but in
fact what they're doing is it's a
non-profit and they're trying to improve
security and privacy for everyone the
organization that runs quad nine is
headquarters in Switzerland which is a
country that is known for privacy uh all
the way to financial privacy and these
kinds of things they actually have
stronger privacy regulations than there
are in the rest of Europe in the
European Union they have the generalized
data protection uh standard regulation
gdpr and in fact that's very strict the
laws in Switzerland are even stricter
and carry actual criminal penalties for
violations so it's in a place where
there is there's no desire to monetize
you the the desire is to take your
information
anonymized and use it to enhance this
Blacklist and we get sources other
sources that feed into this one of those
other sources is IBM's X-Force security
research group so this all enriches the
database and that information is then
shared so everyone that comes along
benefits from everyone else's
contribution to this think of it as a
crowdsourcing but your information is
still anonymized and no more profit
motive none of that because the best
thing here about this is the whole thing
is in fact free you don't pay for it yet
you benefit from it and in fact everyone
benefits from this with the security
capabilities it adds excellent so that's
the method you need to take away is that
go into your network settings and on
whether it be Windows or Mac OS and you
can change your DNS to be
9.9.9.9 therefore quad nine so it's easy
to remember well thanks a lot Jeff you
bet
thanks for watching if you found this
video interesting and would like to
learn more about cyber security please
remember to hit like And subscribe to
this channel